[Music]
hi everyone my name is bashar gupta
as daniel already mentioned i'm the
co-founder and ceo of aperture data
today we want to focus our talk on data
management particularly on visual data
and i want to start by explaining why
luis remix who is our co-founder and cto
will demonstrate uh how in the second
half of the talk
estimates vary but the storage needed by
images or videos of what we refer as
visual data
collected by various types of cameras
across
numerous different industries is
expected to cross 80 zettabytes by 2025.
it's naturally impossible for humans to
pour over all this data and find
relevant information
however the advancements in machine
learning
and data science techniques as you all
are very well aware of
can help businesses across different
domains extract very valuable insights
four years ago back at intel when we
started working on the design for an
end-to-end visual cloud infrastructure
to be used for machine learning on
visual data we spoke to machine learning
researchers in academia and our company
at the beginning we only ever heard
compute
devops and accuracy related challenges
that people envision
in order to make machine learning a
reality anytime you have data
we receive feedback to the effect of
data access can currently be
hidden behind because training takes so
long
um or image sets can just be discarded
after they've been used for training a
particular model
or we're not really worried about
terabytes of data yet
while all those challenges still remain
present
and are being actively addressed in the
last two years the conversation has
shifted to include data
and data platform challenges now we hear
comments and questions like
it's really hard to train on videos can
i avoid
fetching a gigabyte worth of video file
just for two second interval that i need
for training
or can i store multiple annotations per
frame and the annotations may not just
be boxes they could be polygons
um then if they start to get more and
more into like can i store the
embeddings to restart my training from
where i left off
or maybe use them to find similar items
maybe i need to track and snapshot the
subsets of data that i was using to
personalize my machine learning model
and this by no means is a complete list
the challenges in data management are
becoming more front and center
from the actual storage and access to
validating correctness
removing outliers fixing bias today we
want to focus on one of those
the management of this data itself
let's first talk about why now because
we have been streaming
image and video for a long time the
reason we need to rethink our strategy
now
is that we no longer just want to stream
this data
but we want to analyze it more and more
so then a valid follow-up is um given
the number of databases out there
why does visual data management deserve
special discussion
well because images and videos can be
individually large
sometimes even one image can be
gigabytes large
and typically occur in large volume so
it's
common to have millions of images or
videos
databases typically tend to support
operations like
some average count which kind of lose
meaning
in visual data the equivalent and common
operations for example would be
pre-processing tasks like resize scrub
rotate things like that and they can be
performed on images video frames or
videos themselves
as common as these are across multiple
applications
they can also be quite computationally
expensive
so it's the complexity of operations
that is quite unique in this case
then visual data is also typically
accompanied by a lot of metadata
because the metadata doesn't just
contain information
about the visual object itself but also
about the surrounding application
maybe annotations maybe features
describing the contents and so on
so you know going back to you know four
years back when we did start looking at
the problem
because we kind of anticipated some of
these data challenges
um and even to this day we have realized
uh that the lack of a database that
understands visual data
and doesn't just treat them as simple
blobs
manifest challenges over time engineers
basically have to adapt
and glue disparate systems never
designed for visual data
or machine learning they have to insert
data in cloud storage buckets or some
distributed file system
they have to store metadata in one among
the plethora of database choices like
could be relational graph key value or
sometimes even excel
which eventually may not scale well
pre-processing needed for display or
further analytics
in the is then spread across various
components of the pipeline
so concocting such frankenstein
solutions and spreading the
functionality across
not only results in a maintenance
nightmare but also leads to sub-optimal
one-time results that don't necessarily
evolve with the application
beyond just the user impact there is
also a sizable business impact that
results from a misuse or overuse of
resources due to lack of a unified
solution
there is a higher cost due to needing
more engineers or mismatching
engineering skill set
and finally but most importantly is the
market cost
associated with the delays that result
from setting up infrastructure
all this causes businesses to
potentially lose millions of dollars
before
even deploying machine learning in
production
aperture data offers a unique database
aperture db
designed for visual data aperture data
treats
offers treats visual objects as
first-class citizens
by offering native support for images
videos and bounding boxes
naturally we also support pre-processing
and augmentation operations on these
objects
we manage the metadata information as a
knowledge graph that offers
improving insights as your application
keeps enhancing this metadata over time
the metadata can be contextual or
annotation based
we enable visual searches by storing
images or videos besides this contextual
metadata
since feature vectors can be used to
describe contents and images or frames
we also offer the capability to index
and search
feature vectors thus enabling similarity
searches
and as a result of all these key
features
you can actually save hundreds of hours
of data platform engineering time
which eventually leads to a faster
analytics deployment
aperture db can layer on top of existing
cloud
or or a distributed file system storage
containing visual data
and manage various assets it can respond
to queries from
different machine learning frameworks ui
or visualization front-ends
labeling front-ends and can be made part
of an analytics pipeline
the queries can add modify or search
visual data and metadata
annotations or embeddings you can
perform on-the-fly visual pre-processing
and do more machine-related machine
learning related tasks
like data snapshots like taking
snapshots of the data that you were
training
on lewis will demonstrate some of these
features
shortly
with its roots tracing back to intel
days aperture db was always designed for
scale and performance
this is visible from the performance
gains demonstrated against
a state-of-the-art system we set up to
approximate a portion of the
functionality
offered by our database so in this case
we we stored metadata in mysql
sell the files over http file server and
we use opencv
for processing the images all of that
against
our system um so for visual queries
on the yahoo flickr the 100 million
image and video data set
we were up to 35 x faster depending on
the query complexity
and 15x faster on average
since we can perform pre-processing on
visual data near
its storage location rather than you
know transferring it to the client and
then
doing the processing we often get an
unexpected and welcome reduction in
network
usage since the common case is uh
typically transferring a high resolution
image from the storage or
or large video to a low res uh or a
low resolution input to the neural
network or for maybe thumbnail displays
aperture db is currently deployed at a
stealth biotech ai customer
based on the feedback that we've
received after our successful pilot with
them
they were able to save weeks of platform
engineering time
they are already using our database with
over a billion metadata entities and
terabytes corresponding to 300 to 400
million images at this time
uh and they were able to create their
machine learning pipeline with two
two or three fewer uh machine learning
infrastructure engineers
so now i will switch over to uh now luis
can take over for
a demo of how our product works so what
we're going to be doing in this demo
is essentially going over
some exploration of the cocoa data set
so the cocoa data set is a data set
um that has
a lot of information and a lot of a lot
of information
and a lot of metadata associated with
multiple images this is a data set that
it's used for
training uh ml models including object
detection and segmentation of
images and it's it's composed by
roughly um 120 000 images each of those
images
are curated and the annotations have
been very well curated where
we can find information about some of
the bounding boxes as you can see here
and the labels of each of the bounding
boxes
on uh all of their images also some
descriptions of what is the content of
what's going on in the image
and what it's very interesting is we
have pixel level segmentation of each of
the different objects of the image
so what we did for this is essentially
load the entire data set
into aperture db so we can show you how
very easily you can go and explore the
data set and even retrieve the images
apply pre-processing operations and
interact with the data set and even
create
subsets of the data set for running your
specific training
based on some constraints um
and how easy that is given that we
support all the necessary infrastructure
and
and interfaces to very easily access
these images these annotations these
segmentation masks you know
essentially all the information data set
one thing we should notice is that um
even though these demo focused on the
image functionality
we have similar functionality to user
defined
uh entities and uh videos and feature
vectors
that and we actually have some uh demos
that you can try on our website that i'm
gonna be showing you at the end
but this is just focused on images even
though we have a
much richer set of functionalities so
the first thing we're going to be doing
is
tell you a little bit more about how we
have structure our data set
underneath what we have is a graph
structure so we represent all the
metadata
following a property graph and
essentially for this specific data set
what we have the information model in
the following way we have a set of
images
in this case i'm showing just two image
two
images and these two images have some
specific properties and each of those
images are um are connected
to in the graph to some of the bounding
boxes
that have some specific information
about what's the content on the image
um the bounty boxes have their own
properties which we can search and
filter based on and
we also have the segmentation
version or the segmented pixel data
information of each of the images
that it's also connected to the original
image so we're going to be
just just to show you how the
information is structured and how we can
go about
querying this information and retrieving
the information
and curate a new data set even if you
want so
as part of the first exercise and what
we want to show you is how you interact
so with with aperture tv essentially
what we have here is a piece of python
code
and a python interface so what we
do here is import the pdms module vdms
is the name of the open source project
so the connector to aperture db is the
same as the open source project so we're
going to be using that
and essentially what we do is go and
create a connection
to the database that it's running on the
local host in this case
and we're ready to start writing queries
so all of our interface
is based on json so we have a set of
commands and
you can put as many commands as you want
and constitute the transaction
and the operation that you send the
query that you send will be
processed transactionally and operated
transactionally on aperturedb
in this particular case we're going to
be doing something very simple is
finding an image
and of course we can apply some
constraints so we're going to filter
those image
in this specific case but one id i just
want to retrieve a single image by this
id
and i also can specify a list of the
properties
associated with that image that are part
of the image node essentially in the
graph
so we can just go ahead and run this
query so you can see i get an image of a
force the image is
returned as it is on the database and
together with that i also get a piece of
json
that has all the information that i
requested like the date it was captured
the height the width the id of the image
and some information that can be very
easily parsed so
up to this point all we did was filter
an image by an id
now things get more interesting when on
top of just doing uh
a retrieval of the image we can apply
some pre-processing operations
and all we have to do is add a set of
operations as part of the interface
again this is just
json so what we can do here is apply the
set of pre-processing operations as many
operations as we want depending on what
we need
and this is pretty common because when
you
use a data set like this for training
you usually
have some pre-processing steps
either for data augmentation or because
you need to
resize the image or normalize the image
so that it
that it can be input to the new network
so one
one cases you want to run this image
through
resnet and resnet expects a 224 by 224
image so
instead of retrieving the original image
and apply the preprocessing locally
you can make that operation happen on
aperture db
on the server side where the image is
located engine
just transmit um the resize smaller
version of that image
into the client that is going to be
running the processing on top of that
so maybe let me show you let's just run
a single operation
which is a resize as you can see we get
the smaller version of the image
and we can also apply a rotate operation
for example in this case we're going to
be doing a 90 degrees rotation
and we just change the parameters of the
query and we get the transform version
of the image so
all of these very basic operations
um can be performed on the server side
um
and one thing we should note is that
this is not apple
this set of operations not specific to
this data set
actually what we have been paying where
we have been paying particular attention
is to
put in in our interfaith things or
operations
and interfaces that are
application independent and that are
useful for any application that relies
on visual data
essentially all the basic basic building
blocks that
applications rely on visual data needs
from a database
um on top of that we can do even more
complicated
um and and we can increase the
complexity of of the queries that we
want one one thing we can do for example
is filter on many constraints so
in this particular case given that the
image images
have a width and a height maybe i can go
and filter by those
two or as many properties as you want
so in this particular case i say okay i
want only those
images i want multiple images but only
those images that are
um larger than a certain size so we can
go and
formulate a query that way and in this
case we'll retrieve all the images
that um that fulfill with that operation
and another thing we can do we can
always do is essentially change the
format so the images are originally
in jpeg because that's the way the data
set um
that's how the images on the dataset
come from but suppose that you need png
for whatever
reason in your application you changing
and
and doing a transcoding of that is just
as simple as
passing another parameter on your query
and you just run that and you will
receive a png version all of this
operation of resizing
um or even transcoding happens on the
server side
in this case you you will hardly notice
any difference
but the image that we're returning here
is it's a png image
um maybe more importantly for some
applications to do the other way around
we have png
um that compress to have less
smaller compression rate when uh when
compared to p
to jpeg so if you have an original png
you might be interested in retrieving a
jpeg version so that you use less
bandwidth
you can do that very easily with our
interface
so we can have in this background we can
go and do
more interesting things so if you
remember we have bounding boxes and one
of the properties of the bounding boxes
indicate what's the percentage
of the pixels with respect to the larger
image
so if we look at this bounding box this
is telling us that
this image id 34
ha with one specific id
have a bounding box that contains a
horse and it's about 50
of the image so we might go and filter
um images that way so
what we're gonna be doing here is go and
find all the bounding boxes where we
have horses
and essentially find the bounding box
and retrieve the associated image
and we can do that for multiple bounty
boxes of course
so we're gonna be doing a finding about
bounding box
filtering by the label of the category
name
in this case horse and then say okay i
only want those images with
uh the horse is at least 40 of the pixel
of the number of pixels that you have in
the image and we can go
and find the images associated with
those founding boxes
and at the same time apply a resize
operation so
we are able to express all these graph
traversal
and retrieval of an image and
pre-processing operations
by simply using the interface and
without having to do
much work or relying on multiple systems
or multiple frameworks to
to do all this basic work so um
of course the graph traversal can be as
complex as your operation requires in
this case we just do
a graph traversal of of two of
one level essentially but you can go as
much as we want our interface allows you
to
essentially do as a deep crafter as well
as your application needs
so we just go and run here and we get
all the
images where we have forces that are
where the image is
larger than uh 40 where the
the amount of pixels of the force
occupies more than 40
and we also can get the coordinates of
the bounding boxes of the horses and all
that information that can be very easily
parsed because you get the response as a
json object
so what we did here and in order to
go and do some more complex stuff is we
encapsulated the function that um or the
query that
i just showed you into this function
where we just passed the parameters we
just say okay
the label and the percentage of the area
and we limit the number of results it's
just for demonstration purposes
what we can do here is go the other way
around we can
find certain image and then go and find
the bounding boxes associated with those
images
in order to retrieve that and and um
and draw the boundary boxes on top of
the image
so this is just as easy as finding first
the image based on an
id and then finding the bounding box
associated with those images
and we can just go and run that query
and as you can see i
from a single place from aperture db i
can get both the images apply whatever
pre-processing operation
retrieve the bounding boxes and get all
the information ready in place for me to
go and draw the bounding boxes there
um and we can go one extra mile
one extra step and do the same query but
on top of retrieving the bounding boxes
associated with the image
we can find the the image that contains
a segmentation
that is associated with the original
image so that we get
all the bounding boxes and all the
segmented versions and when we go around
this query we get something like this we
get
the original image all the bounding
boxes associated with that
and um a segmented version of of
that image here in this particular case
we got two images as a result
so you can see the segmented versions of
both
so the good thing about this is that um
it's very easy to go and explore this
data set once you have a database that
supports
all the necessary interfaces that you
need in order to retrieve all the
metadata associated with the images the
images themselves and whatever
pre-processing operations that you need
on top of that
so one of the things that we did as well
was
um based on the
this wrapper function that we showed you
before
where we just go and change the label
and specify what's the area
because we have that information model
wrap around this and create a very
simple function
i can even show you the code later but
the function is very small and
that will allow us to create a person
like
custom data sets as a subset of the
cocoa data set so
again i'm going to show you this is the
basic query where we just retrieve
images of people where the area is at
least 50 percent
we get some examples but we can wrap
that function
and um that's what we did here in order
to build the data set
so in this particular case you might be
interested to build a data set with only
furniture
with the different metadata pieces of
furniture that you have on your data set
and you can specify as many labels as
you want in this case i want to retrieve
the images that have dining table
bed tv or couch and i want
200 images for of each of these classes
and one of the filtering that i can do
is i want to make sure that at least
30 percent of that image is um
corresponds to each of the objects so
that
if say i want to train that i want to
make sure that um
for example i'm going to be able to
train off on
images on tvs that are large and octv's
that are very very far away and really
hard to see on the images
now aperture tv is fully concurrent
so we can create this data set here
and we're going to create a new custom
data set here
so we can in parallel go and retrieve
all these different images and
in this particular case the
implementation that we did is retrieve
in parallel each of the
different tags that we have so we can
just go ahead and run this
and just by writing less than 50 lines
of code you can create a personalized
data set
um and it takes in this particular case
three seconds to retrieve all those
um 800 images that are
here in the new data set that we have
created and we have a train and test set
um of all the different categories for
example
bed and we have all the images here
so we have all the images that um that
constitutes our new data set that we can
go and explore
so um
um it is very easy to create these new
data sets
um the same way we can go and create
one for animals right we just go and
change the labels and it will be
just as fast because everything will run
in parallel in our database and retrieve
all the images
um so uh
essentially the other thing that we're
working on
is in just
creating like a pie torch data set or a
tensorflow data set
by just changing the parameters of what
data set is
it's created that will allow users to
build new
data sets that are um ready in the pi
torch and tensorflow format
um that it's built upon
going and querying aperture tv so we
will just go and specify say i want to
create a new
pi torch data set of images with these
stacks and
with whatever properties constraints
that you want and
um given that aperture db has all the
necessary interfaces
it will go query the database and
retrieve all the images that you want in
the format that you want
so this is some of the things that you
can do
with having by having a powerful
interface
as aperture db does so um
we have another set of demos that you
can go and try one of the demos is on
medical imaging
we have a more complicated pipeline and
that works for medical imaging that we
have done
in that particular case the medical
imaging graph it's
slightly more complicated because we
have patients we have visits we have
scans and within the scans we have
multiple images
so you can model significantly much more
complex
data in this particular case we can go
and run queries like give me
all the brain scans of patients over 80
years old that have received some
specific
drug treatment so you can formulate that
query and both retrieve all the metadata
associated with the patients and
retrieve
images and
we have another functionality as well
with respect to feature vectors that
will allow you to do
to work on surveillance applications or
even smart retail or smart cities that
uh
you can extract feature vectors for from
faces for example
and we allow uh we have interfaces that
will allow you to insert those feature
vectors
do similarity search which is
essentially finding similar
similar faces for example um
and retrieve images associated with
those similar faces
um those are all unified interfaces that
we support and
um you can go and try so
we are rolling out our new website if
you go
and go to www.aperturedata.io
you can find the same demo that i just
showed you and many more demos by going
here to demo trial
and for example if you want the demo
that i just showed you the code
data set you just put your email here
and
in two minutes essentially this will
instantiate the demo in google cloud
and within two minutes you will receive
an email with um
with the information access so you can
go and try so go and try yourself you
have many different demos to go over
that use different parts of the
interface
and of course we have all the
documentation of the
interface right here so
the last thing where i mentioned is that
um we are also hiring
so if you are interested in the project
or if you know anyone who might be
interested in the project as well just
send us an email
and we'll be happy to to talk more and
of course go
and make use of the cloud trials that
you have
and if you have further questions there
is also contact form there or
just send us an email